[Música]
mariotto no se rinde el primer ministro
ucraniano denizet miguel sostiene que
los cerca de 3.000 militares que se
refugian en una fábrica de acero
lucharán hasta el final y rusia insiste
que si no deponen las armas los
eliminará
queda exactamente una semana para la
segunda vuelta presidencial en francia
daniel leppén se defendió de las
críticas de manuel ma con quien la llamo
escéptica climática mientras los dos
aspirantes mantienen sus diferencias
sobre la política exterior y se alistan
para el único debate presidencial antes
de los comicios
ocho mujeres jóvenes siguen
desaparecidas en la ciudad mexicana de
monterrey y en menos de un mes se han
emitido cerca de 20 denuncias de
desaparición en esta ciudad sus familias
y organizaciones de derechos humanos
denuncian que no son hechos aislados
bienvenidos a las noticias de france 24
yo soy maría clara calle y es un saludo
es un placer acompañarlos empezamos esta
emisión en ucrania los cerca de 2.500
soldados y 400 mercenarios que rusia
dice que están en una planta de acero en
mariupol continúan sin rendirse mientras
que denis es miguel el primer ministro
ucraniano sostiene que lucharán hasta el
final ellos son el último bastión que
tiene ucrania antes de que la ciudad
caiga bajo el control de moscú el vocero
del ministerio de defensa ruso ígor
konashénkov advirtió que quienes sigan
resistiendo serán eliminados les
contamos más en el siguiente informe
se les dio un ultimátum para que
depusieran las armas a cambio de salvar
sus vidas pero las tropas ucranianas que
quedan en la ciudad de mariupol en el
sureste del país han ignorado el plato
del ejército ruso para rendirse y
sostienen que lucharán hasta el final
no la ciudad aún no ha caído todavía
están nuestras presas militares nuestros
soldados por los que lucharán hasta el
final y por ahora siguen en mario pull
and us for now de gestión en mayo
mariupol ha estado sitiada durante siete
semanas y las tropas rusas afirman que
ahora controlan la mayor parte de la
ciudad portuaria los combatientes
ucranianos que quedan se han refugiado
en el distrito industrial del acero en
el laberinto de edificios y paisajes
subterráneos que conforman la fábrica
siderúrgica asusta al cercado ahora por
las fuerzas rusas es el último gran foco
de resistencia en mariupol
los restos del ejército ucraniano y un
gran equipo de civiles están básicamente
rodeados por las fuerzas rusas siguen
luchando pero parece que por la forma en
que el ejército ruso se comporta en
mariupol han decidido arrasar la ciudad
a cualquier precio
en in cost después de su fracaso en la
toma de 10 captura el mariupol sería una
victoria simbólica para moscú los
separatistas creando un corredor
terrestre entre rusia y crimea y
controlando la segunda gran ciudad
ucraniana en caer en manos del kremlin
después de gerzón y por tercer día
consecutivo hubo bombardeos en kharkiv
la segunda ciudad más importante de
ucrania el gobierno local afirma que
misiles impactaron en el centro y en el
suburbio de salt il caffè al menos cinco
personas murieron y 20 resultaron
heridas el alcalde de la ciudad igor ter
kof afirmó que están evacuando a civiles
pero reconoció que ya no hay lugares
totalmente seguros en kharkiv e invitó a
los ciudadanos a que se vayan
pues siempre rinde más
estamos trasladando las personas a
lugares que son menos peligrosos porque
ya no hay lugares completamente seguros
en kharkiv allí proporcionamos un lugar
para vivir comida caliente ducha y ayuda
médica
hago un llamado a todos aquellos que
viven bajo bombardeo interminable para
que se vayan nuestros voluntarios los
ayudarán a hacerlo como
los constantes bombardeos en heart que
han destruido gran parte de la ciudad
donde antes de la guerra vivían 14
millones de personas los civiles han
sido los más afectados por la ofensiva
las más recientes estimaciones del
presidente ucraniano volodymyr selenski
es que tan sólo en los últimos cuatro
días han muerto 18 civiles por los
ataques en harkis andrés granadillo nos
cuenta
la segunda ciudad más grande de ucrania
bajo fuego kharkiv es uno de los puntos
estratégicos que está siendo bombardeado
constantemente por las tropas rusas
desde que el presidente putin detuvo su
ofensiva contra kiev ha vuelto a poner
sus ojos en el flanco este de ucrania
los principales afectados son los
civiles
después de la primera salva oí llegar la
siguiente ronda e inmediatamente se vio
humo negro vi que estaba cerca de casa y
corría a ella entonces un joven corrió
al patio y me ayudó a salvar al gato
todo cada parte de mí está temblando
dt
los habitantes del lugar llamaban
insistentemente pidiendo ayuda a los
bomberos
y
volví a llamar a los bomberos me dijeron
estamos en camino pero también nos están
bombardeando les pregunté cuándo van a
llegar y me dijeron no lo sabemos y aquí
empezó a arder todo pero todo empezó por
el tejado
tras 25 minutos de espera la ayuda llegó
en total 33 vehículos de rescate de
incendios y unos 150 efectivos
participaron en la lucha contra el fuego
de hoy
los edificios gubernamentales de los
alrededores están ya demolidos por los
anteriores ataques aéreos rusos que han
golpeado la asediada ciudad en la que
vivían 14 millones de personas antes de
la guerra cerca de 5 millones de
ucranianos han abandonado el país para
huir de las atrocidades de la guerra que
inició el 24 de febrero
queda una semana para definir quién será
el próximo presidente de francia el
actual mandatario de manuel majo aspira
a la reelección su contrincante en la
segunda vuelta del 24 de abril será la
ultraconservadora ma jin de penn uno de
los puntos que los divide es el medio
ambiente ayer bajo señaló que el epen es
una escéptica climática a lo que la
candidata respondió hoy que jamás lo ha
sido otra gran diferencia entre los dos
aspirantes es la política exterior al
punto que el epen ha hecho propuestas
que rompen con el trabajo internacional
que ha adelantado el actual presidente
francés los aspirantes al elíseo
defenderán sus ideas en el único debate
presidencial que habrá y que se
realizará el próximo 20 de abril
aquí les explicamos cuáles son sus
diferencias en las relaciones
internacionales
la rusia vladimir putin ha sido durante
mucho tiempo admirada e incluso
cortejada por marine le pen una posición
muy criticada desde la invasión rusa de
ucrania por lo que la cantidad de
agrupación nacional ha querido dejar
clara su visión se declara partidaria de
reforzar los vínculos entre la otan y
moscú
es tan pronto como la guerra entre rusia
y ucrania haya terminado y tengamos un
tratado de paz lo pondré un acercamiento
estratégico entre la otan y rusia y con
colotto en el área
otra medida defendida por más que le pen
la retirada de francia del mando militar
integrado de la otan para recuperar más
soberanía asegura la candidata en
segundo lugar quiere poner fin a la
cooperación industrial con alemania una
posición justificada por los intereses
divergentes entre ambos países aunque la
candidata ya no defiende el éxito y el
abandono del euro sigue siendo crítica
con las limitaciones impuestas por la
legislación europea
una historia totalmente diferente es la
de su rival emanuel macaco que es
abiertamente pro europeo
el presidente saliente aboga por una
unión europea fuerte y energéticamente
independiente y
la lucha que estamos librando no es sólo
una lucha por francia es una lucha por
europa porque el proyecto de
ultraderecha que tenemos delante va en
contra del proyecto que yo defiendo en
nombre de muchos de los que están aquí
es un proyecto oculto ahora es más
ambiguo pero es un proyecto para salir
de europa
después de catalogar como muerte a la
otan en 2019 marco instó a la alianza a
unificarse justificando su decisión por
la guerra que está a las puertas de la
unión europea también pidió que se
aplicaran fuertes sanciones contra moscú
el actual presidente es partidario de la
estabilidad política en tiempos de
crisis una estabilidad que pretende
encarnar
ahora hablemos de américa latina' al
menos ocho mujeres siguen desaparecidas
en la zona metropolitana de monterrey en
mexico en el último mes se han hecho
entre 19 y 22 denuncias de desaparición
en esa ciudad de jóvenes que tienen
entre 12 y 26 años sus familias
denuncian deficiencias en la
investigación y afirman que no son
hechos aislados antes hablamos con marta
canseco periodista y activista por los
derechos de las mujeres ella nos explicó
a qué se debe esta ola de desapariciones
en monterrey y en el país
buenas noches maría clara mira decirte
que en méxico desaparecen al día 7
mujeres en nuestro país son las que las
que queda registro pero el número es
mayor evidentemente en los en lo que va
del año del 1 de enero al 14 de abril
han desaparecido en nuestro país
748 mujeres
55 de ellas en el nuevo león no
solamente en la ciudad de monterrey que
es la capital sino en nuevo león en todo
el estado la característica que tiene
nueva leones que hace frontera con texas
y entonces pues evidentemente es mucho
más fácil sacarlas de del país los
estados con mayor número de mujeres
desaparecidas es así mira es estado de
méxico ciudad de méxico monterrey este
perdón morelos y en cuarto lugar nuevo
león el problema se está agudizando y
evidentemente no ayuda mucho la posición
del gobierno al respecto dice que es
normal
el gobierno mexicano le parece normal
que siete mujeres al día desaparezcan en
nuestro país ahora dice que están
trabajando al respecto pero no terminan
de decirnos cómo es que están trabajando
recordar también mari aclara que en el
en el estado de nuevo léon no hay una
ley contra trata la principal cantidad
de mujeres que están desapareciendo
desde los 15 a los 19 años lo que habla
por supuesto de un fenómeno de trata en
esa zona y este estado no tiene ninguna
ley que prevenga ni castigue la trata
a propósito de méxico el instituto
nacional de migración de ese país
informó hoy que en lo que va del año han
interceptado a cerca de 115 mil
migrantes
las cifras que contabilizan hasta el 13
de abril señalan que el 15 por ciento de
ellos eran menores de edad una sexta
parte de todos los migrantes retenidos
provenían de honduras y otra sexta parte
de guatemala que son los dos países con
más nacionales retenidos en mexico
seguidos por cuba nicaragua y el
salvador la cifra de 2022 es alta
teniendo en cuenta que en todo el 2021
méxico deportó da más de 114 mil
extranjeros
termina la emergencia sanitaria oficial
en brasil que inició el 3 de febrero de
2020 así lo anunció hoy el ministro de
salud marcelo quiroga la cartera
sostiene que tomó la decisión porque ya
el escenario epidemiológico generado por
la pandemia del cobi 19 mejoró y que
además los ciudadanos han respondido
bien a la campaña de vacunación
actualmente el gigante sudamericano
tiene uno de los picos más bajos de
contagios de coronavirus con menos de 20
mil casos diarios lejos de los más de
100 mil que se registraban en una sola
jornada durante el pico que vivió brasil
en enero
y en noticias de asia la junta militar
de mianmar dio este domingo el
tradicional perdón por el año nuevo
budista más de 1600 personas fueron
liberadas de prisión sin embargo no
habrían administrado a los presos
políticos detenidos desde el primero de
febrero de 2021 cuando el gobierno de
aung san suu fue derrocado y miles de
manifestantes se vuelcan a las calles a
protestar en contra de la junta militar
luís muñoz nos amplia
un perdón para mil 619 presos en mianmar
la amnistía por el año nuevo budista es
habitual pero este año ha sido mucho
menor que los 23.000 de 2021 el evento
congregó a las familias frente a la
prisión de insein pero fuentes de fp
aseguran que los presos políticos
detenidos durante el gobierno de la
actual junta militar no fueron liberados
aunque mi hija sólo tiene 19 años es muy
activa en política estoy orgullosa de
ella
estoy esperando afuera de la prisión con
la esperanza de que sea liberada un
perdón que no ha terminado con la
represión de la junta militar estas
imágenes muestran algunas de las más de
cien aldeas quemadas por el ejército en
los últimos meses pero la represión
también va acompañada de una fuerte
resistencia desde las fuerzas populares
de defensa pero también desde la cultura
como esta comparsa de cantantes y
comediantes que recorre la selva para
hacer pedagogía
pero que la gente apoyará cualquier
movimiento contra los militares puedes
revelarte contra ellos a través del
equipo el electropop o el tanga
la gente está lista para apoyarte en
este tiempo porque todos quieren luchar
contra la dictadura militar
el 1 de febrero de 2021 el ejército dio
un golpe de estado al gobierno de aung
san suu kyi acusándola de fraude
electoral desde entonces según datos de
una ong local más de 1.700 civiles han
muerto y más de 13.000 personas han sido
arrestadas
y que no viertan al océano las aguas que
tratan de la antigua planta nuclear de
fukushima ese es el llamado que hicieron
hoy miles de manifestantes en tokio
estas personas protestaron contra la
política nuclear de japón que incluye el
plan de tirar el agua al océano pacifico
posiblemente antes de abril de 2023
el gobierno nipón buscó el respaldo de
la agencia internacional de energía
atómica el organismo viajará al país
nuevamente para realizar más revisiones
pero muchos japoneses piden que sean
científicos locales y otros organismos
los que inspeccionan el agua tratada
para ver si puede o no contaminar los
mares
[Música]
y a partir de mañana inicia en france24
directo américa edición nocturna de
lunes a viernes a las 19 horas en bogotá
quito lima estaremos con santiago lópez
y valentina torres sánchez para 2 horas
de información con las noticias el
debate y las actualizaciones de los
deportes y la economía
los esperamos en este programa por lo
pronto sigan aquí en france 24
[Música]